breaking news inflation came in at 7.9
year-over-year growth this is the
highest inflation has been in over 40
years if you haven't been paying
attention i suggest you start paying
attention right now this is absolutely
mind-boggling numbers if we go ahead and
we take a look my brother joe had a
great tweet that he said this is the
tenth consecutive month with inflation
numbers coming in at five percent or
higher that's wild but imagine if the
numbers weren't manipulated and that's
true these are the official numbers the
unofficial numbers are likely more than
double-digit inflation in the united
states right now if we go ahead and we
actually take a look at what the
inflation numbers are showing us from a
cpi standpoint we can see that 7.9
is the highest that we've had in the
united states since the early 80s but
then if we take out food and energy look
at core inflation that's now 6.4
also the highest since we've had since
the early 80s now if we go ahead and we
take a look deeper into those cpi
numbers what the hell is all of this
growth coming from in prices well of
course used cars up 41
but if you're an average american you're
paying 38 more for gasoline to fill up
your tank right now you also are paying
more than 8.4 percent more for food at
home and of course if you want to buy a
new car that costs you 12 percent more
and your electricity bill is 9
higher as well this is unsustainable for
millions and millions and millions of
americans around the country ultimately
we have to come to a solution but if we
go ahead and we take a look at shelter
shelter is one of the biggest components
as well that shelter makes up 33 percent
of the index and it's still being wildly
understated i would argue even
manipulate it they currently are
reporting that it's only plus 4.7
year-over-year but rents are up 18 over
the last year and home prices are up 19
my guess and as charlie's saying here
inflation is much much higher than the
7.9 percent now if we compare the united
states to other countries around the
world the us is not doing too hot the
united states is only doing better than
russia poland brazil argentina turkey
and venezuela now this 7.9
number compared to all these other
countries is really important to
understand this is for the month of
february which was before russia invaded
ukraine it's before oil prices exploded
20 to 25 percent higher before wheat and
nickel and all of these other commodity
prices exploded if you think 7.9
as the official number was bad in
february just wait till you see what
they're gonna show us in march now if we
continue what we can see here is that
the us wages have failed to keep pace
with rising prices for 11 months in a
row and charlie saying correctly it's
gonna get worse before it gets better
free money isn't free and we're just
starting to learn that lesson ultimately
the average hourly earnings in real
terms is down people are getting paid
less money today in purchasing power
terms than they were just two years ago
and so ultimately inflation ravages the
bottom 45 percent of americans they have
no investable assets they get paid less
money today than they did previously all
of their savings are being eroded away
as they sit in cash and inflation
officially at 7.9 unofficially is more
into the double digits at the end of the
day there's no politician or central
banker that has a solution you have to
make a choice do we want inflation or do
we want a recession pick your poison
because ultimately the individual people
have to protect themselves and as long
as inflation continues to rage on
everyone is being put into a worse
situation hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time